Where to start knitting?
If you have cards that were pre-punched
specifically for your machine,
and the card has a line printed,
you simply need to line up up
the line and start knitting.
But cards from different
manufacturers don't always line up.
Think about this. The punch card mechanism
itself lives inside the body
of your knitting machine.
And the different brands and models have
different mechanisms and they have unique
positions within the machine bed itself.
I like to imagine little fingers that are
inside the mechanism that read
the holes of the card.
Now, the fingers in one machine may be
positioned an inch down from the top edge
of the card reader and the fingers
in another machine may be half inch down
from the top edge of the card reader.
If you insert the same card in two
different machines
and line up the pre-printed line,
the fingers might be reading a different
row and the first row that knits will
be different on the two machines.
Now sure, there are some rules out there
about Silver Singer versus Brother and
there may be color coding on the cards.
But more importantly, you need
to understand that there is a difference.
You might have mystery cards and you don't
know if they were designed
for your machine.
You may have inherited some cards
that were punched by a knitter and they
don't have any color or any indication
on them of what machine
they were designed for.
The best way to find out what the
first rows of your card on your
machine is, is to try it.